the Joe Rogan experience and their
poison so hold on go up to the top so I
could read the thing oh you're human big
hybrids created in the lab here are the
facts
mmm whenever you hear that they've
already been making people out of pigs
right by the time you hear that by the
time it gets to us I mean how far down
the ladder are we on the information
food chain you know yeah I mean who the
people in this pickle they're pigs lungs
are breathe and what in the [ __ ] yeah
watch Pig blong pig lungs filter human
blood in a lab holy [ __ ] man that's I
have a Google Alert set for that watch
pig lungs filter human blood in the lab
you'll get overwhelmed it's every day
just don't stop with the pig blood yeah
what screw a human ear on a lot on a rat
did they they grew a human ear ear on a
on the back of a mouse yeah I don't know
what that was about
looked like a tree yeah yeah that's what
it looks like he does look exactly like
that's weird
[ __ ] it's weird yeah that's what Medusa
meth came from people growing getting
that you know right I like snake head
right maybe you just got distorted over
the years to be like you froze like a
stone but instead of just you were just
covered like a rock yeah I mean a
disease like that if you've got that
[ __ ] a thousand years ago people
absolutely be convinced you were cursed
yeah like something did that to you a
demon possessed you well think about
like the logic to early medicine you
know yeah it's like it's like your head
hurts and we should let some air out of
it look it's off that Coach holes in
your head yeah how about pressure
seizure they thought you were you were
possessed yeah I'll give you a seizure
Steve Martin sketch on SNL I'm the
barber remember that feels like medieval
barber which is like their medicine man
you know he's like trust me huh who's
the barber here we're just gonna drain
your face you know if like it's built
all of his remedies were just death I
watched The Exorcist again the other
night whoa
did go through the head that's what a
lobotomy was they go through the eyeball
right through your eye right through the
night I thought that's going up here oh
wow I thought it was going up there no
they just scramble it stir it around
she magic right a great idea Jesus
Christ Linda no anesthesia no SD Oh
spike in my eye I think they put you
under times I didn't I think oh Jesus
Christ sometimes they didn't sometimes
they just nuked your brain while you're
sitting there they're scrambling it
around just imagine that they did that
what like what year are they doing it
that way dude they did it a lot in 1900
of that kid right above where your
cursor is right there BAM whoa whoa they
lobotomize that kid look at his eyes are
all swollen up hugging the blood holy
[ __ ] they did it to accounts dude they
did it to a kid like he just needed some
adderall holy [ __ ] there was a I feel
like there was a place they were doing
him so often that they had the they
couldn't even do as many as I needed
there were hundreds a day what yeah
please do oh my god that's insane you
imagine that they thought that that was
a good thing to do it's insane and and
but they thought that was a good thing
to do during the time where you can take
pictures yeah look these are photo
cameras existed yeah cameras in modern
era holy [ __ ] yeah and that was going on
in lobotomies were going on like that
one of the Kennedys had it all about of
me
what yeah there's a Kennedy sister who
had a lobotomy for real yeah that [ __ ]
was going on into like the 50s and 60s
remember oh remember 100% flew one flew
over the cocoa Cuckoo's Nest
that's like the end of the movie did
they lobotomize him at the end of the
minute did they electric shock him well
he was kind of done he was like forth or
not the mouth yeah I don't know if they
did it with ink was electric shock
though wasn't it yeah but I I don't know
if it was you know the same outcome okay
hmm
look at this during its heyday in the
1940s and 1950s lobotomy was performed
on some 40,000 patients in the United
States and around 10,000 in Western
Europe holy [ __ ] the procedure became
popular because there were was no
alternative and because it was seen to
alleviate several social crisis's
overcrowding in psychiatric institutions
and the increasing cost of caring for
mentally ill patients so they couldn't
take care of him so they just
Hambledon fed him gruel yeah the guy was
doing 20 to 25 a day
unlike unlike now and we just let them
wander the streets [ __ ] man what the
[ __ ] man that's crazy how many people
that is yeah look up the Kennedy I think
it's one of like JFK sister's got a
lobotomy
dude I was in Fresno recently let's
doing a gig get a meal about it I was
doing a gig and rosemary Kennedy mmm 19
18 mentally impaired
[Applause]